très fortes tensions autour de la crise
russo ukrainienne dans le donbass dans
l'est de l'ukraine et bombardements
s'intensifient pour le deuxième jour
consécutif les séparatistes pro-russes
de l'est de l'ukraine ont annoncé leur
intention d'évacuer vers la russie les
civils des régions sécessionnistes
à kiev la population est toujours
inquiètes juniac et ida à kiev
eh bien il ya évidemment un sentiment
d'inquiétude de la part des habitants
ici à kiev même si nous sommes à 800
kilomètres du donbass de ce territoire
séparatiste les habitants ici pensent
tinqueux qu'un conflit est possible dans
cette zone aérée dire ils ne sont pas
surpris par les bombardements qui ceux
qui ont eu lieu entre hier et
aujourd'hui puisque nous ont-ils répété
ça fait huit ans qu'il ya un conflit
dans l'est du pays il n'y a toutefois
pas de sentiment de panique la vie suit
son cours normalement ici dans la
capitale il ya toutefois un sentiment de
résignation face à ce qu'il nomme une
attitude très agressive de la part de
moscou on a pu voir aussi aujourd'hui
quelque chose d' extrêmement intéressant
ce qui est un élan de solidarité
nationale
ici tout le monde se sont concernés par
ce qui se passe dans l'est du pays que
ce soit dans la capitale à l'ouest tout
le monde se sent vraiment concerné on a
vu ce matin par exemple rassemblement à
un mémorial en hommage aux victimes du
soulèvement 2014 il se situe à quelques
dizaines de mètres de la place maïdan
des anonymes sont venus assister d'abord
à une messe vers 10h30 ce matin et ont
ensuite déposé des petits anges en
papier en gage de paix en signe de paix
plutôt certains veulent encore croire
qu'ici une guerre peut être évité avec
la russie et moscou continuent de
démentir toute intention belliqueuse la
russie assure avoir entamé le retrait de
soldats mais les pays occidentaux jugent
que les mouvements de troupes reflète
une offensive imminente
joe biden présidait une réunion
téléphonique avec plusieurs dirigeants
mondiaux dont emmanuel macron anthony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine va avoir une entrevue avec
sergueï lavrov son homologue en fin de
semaine prochaine on écoute anthony
blinken puis vladimir poutine
tout ce que nous voyons y compris au
cours des dernières 24 48 heures fait
partie d'un scénario déjà en cours qui
consiste à créer de fausses provocation
puis à répondre à ces provocations
et enfin à commettre une nouvelle
agression contre l'ukraine
tout ce que kiev doit faire c'est
s'asseoir à la table des négociations
avec les représentants du dombass et
s'entendre sur des mesures politiques
militaires économiques et humanitaires
pour mettre fin au conflit est plutôt ça
arrivera mieux ce sera malheureusement
en ce moment on assiste au contraire à
une aggravation de la situation dans la
province